I have such a funny voicemail to play
today as many of you know we don't swear
on the David Pakman show like sometimes
there will be swears on my YouTube live
streams because those are only on
YouTube and swearing is okay but because
the show is on nearly 200 radio and
television stations and a lot of these
most of them are bound by FCC
regulations we keep the show FCC safe
because we don't want to get our
affiliate stations find in any way I got
a call from a very sweet sounding mom of
a young David Pakman show viewer or
presume david pakman show viewer who
says that her kid is picking up a lot of
swearing for me and from me and of
course I don't swear on the show I think
that this mom has me mixed up with Kyle
kolinsky of secular talk who swears like
a sailor take a listen to this yes good
evening mr. Pakman I am the mother of
one of your subscribers she's a huge fan
of yours
but unfortunately he's imitating you a
lot and swearing a lot which is just
under coming for a young man I wanted to
ask you politely if you might be able to
just be aware that you have some young
listeners right and not swear as much
thank you very much yeah we don't swear
on the show can't be me so I would check
again with your son whether he's picking
up the swearing from me or from Kyle
kolinsky or from somebody else but I
think there is a case of mistaken
identity here it is definitely not me
that is doing the swearing although he
sounds like a great kid if he's watching
progressive independent media we've got
a great bonus show for you today we will
talk about the latest allegations
against Alex Jones they involve child
porn insanely enough we will talk about
the evolution of the eyes of dogs to
appeal to humans and our emotions and we
will also talk about a Confederate
monument in Nashville that has been
vandalized with the words they were
racist it's anti racist vandalism
against a Confederate monument or as
maybe someone like Alex Jones might
suggest is it a false flag meant to make
the anti-racists look bad all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
WWE
komm to become a member and get instant
access to the award-winning awards we've
created and given ourselves
award-winning bonus show